[Música]
mi madre es la única mujer de mi familia
que sobrevivió al cáncer hoy está bien y
más fuerte que nunca pero formar parte
de una familia en donde el cáncer fue un
tema latente fue uno de los puntos de
partida para encontrar mi vocación como
cirujano dentista y hoy integrar equipos
de trabajo donde rehabilitamos personas
que por cáncer accidentes o temas
congénitos perdieron parte de su rostro
así como el cáncer de mama ovarios o
próstata el cáncer también te puede
aparecer en el rostro y generar tumores
que para poder curar al paciente en
ocasiones tendrían que perder
lamentablemente parte del rostro también
pero si estuviéramos en la decisión de
tener una cirugía para librarnos de un
tumor o perder la vida
es muy probable que escojamos operarnos
pero lo que sucede es que cuando el
riesgo ya pasó quizás nos veamos al
espejo y quizás no sea esto lo que
estábamos imaginando estaremos
agradecidos por mantenernos con vida
pero no dejaremos de buscar
oportunidades para sentirnos mejor
si perdemos parte de un rostro es como
que nos quiten una parte de lo que somos
esto afecta cómo nos sentimos y quiénes
nos sentimos esto impacta en la
percepción de identidad de cada persona
y para la recuperación de estas
pacientes ideal sería que una cirugía
repare todo pero así como una cirugía no
te puede devolver una mano hay partes
del rostro como un ojo que no se pueden
devolver por una operación sea por la
complejidad del tratamiento por la salud
del paciente que no permite más
procedimientos o bien por su propia
voluntad tienen que existir prótesis
como alternativa de solución así como
hay prótesis de dientes prótesis de
cadera o prótesis de piernas que son
elementos artificiales acoplándose o
integrándose al cuerpo para poder
recuperar capacidades existen también
prótesis para rostros
quería mostrar un ejemplo de prótesis de
rostro un paciente portador de una
prótesis como ésta
y por si aún no ven el límite este es el
área que cubre dicha prótesis la
especialidad que se encarga de estos
tratamientos es la rehabilitación book o
maxilofacial es una especialidad del
cirujano dentista y que se encarga a
modo de rehabilitación de todas estas
condiciones más serias y complejas de
los huesos maxilares rostro ósea dentro
y fuera de la boca
solo en cuba existen con una población
de 11 millones de personas
15 en 15 años 18.000 casos atendidos
y en uruguay que son 3 millones de
personas por día reciben 8 pacientes ni
perú ni brasil tienen cifras nacionales
referenciales de prótesis pero si
extrapolamos las cifras de cáncer para
brasil en el 2019 se esperan 40.000
nuevos pacientes por año
y perú haciendo referencia al instituto
nacional de enfermedades neoplásicas
sólo en el servicio de cabeza y cuello
reciben mil consultas por mes se suman
las especialidades como cirugía plástica
otorrino oftalmología entre otras así
como los pacientes que por accidentes o
malformaciones congénitas suman una
lista no tengo cómo saber cuántos de
todo este universo van a requerir de la
intervención de un rehabilitador
bucomaxilofacial pero si tan sólo fuera
5% de todo este universo esto ya
representa una demanda mucho más alta de
lo que decenas de especialistas
podríamos cuidar
otro agravante es que estos pacientes
lamentablemente se encuentran o con
dificultades económicas o en condición
de pobreza y mientras menos recursos
tenga el paciente más tardía suele ser
la detección de dicho cáncer y menos
acceso a tratamientos para entender el
problema de manera general este paciente
se encuentra bajo un sistema con un
círculo vicioso porque no existen en los
hospitales las plazas necesarias para
poder atenderlos ya que no hay
legislación específica y dicha
legislación no genera la infraestructura
necesaria porque tampoco hay
especialistas que lo demanden en ese
sentido la ausencia de una escuela
formadora de especialistas es también un
problema de salud pública
el problema no queda solo porque para
poder crear una estos de estas prótesis
tenemos que preguntar diferentes tipos
de procedimientos complejos para el
propio profesional por dar un ejemplo
para crearla tengo que partir de una
impresión de una copia fiel del rostro
de mi paciente a través de materiales
que colocamos en una región extensa del
rostro y que en ocasiones incluso deben
ingresar por parte de la nariz orejas o
posarse sobre ojos cerrados si fuera el
caso a partir de esa copia
tenemos que crear una escultura con la
forma y encaje de dicha prótesis estas
esculturas me hacen recordar mucho las
esculturas que se hacen en estos museos
de cera
que hacen para artistas famosos solo que
en vez de estar de repente el meses
trabajando en esta obra para estos
museos nosotros debemos tener al
paciente sentado con nosotros
esculpiendo esta forma
hasta que lleguemos a una forma que nos
guste además que cumpla todas las
funciones una vez que tengamos dicha
escultura esta prótesis tendrá que ser
de una silicona que es principalmente
una silicona especial de grado médico y
dicha silicona es transparente
transparente y tendrá que ser coloreada
tal cual como un artista pintaría su
paleta de colores para un cuadro
múltiples colores serán reproducidos y
luego colocados en el molde con la
curiosidad que este progreso no podrá
ser evaluado por nosotros sino hasta que
terminemos de colocar oportunamente
todos estos colores en el lugar tiempo y
momento correctos
cerremos este molde lo abramos y cabe la
posibilidad que no encontremos un
resultado que nos satisface con esto
tendríamos que repetir toda esta parte
del color si todo sale bien el tiempo de
vida media útil de esta rehabilitación
será de 2 años
eso significa que todo este conjunto de
procesos se verán que se ha repetido en
dos años
cada paciente representa un desafío
gigante y que requiere de entre 14 a 24
horas de trabajo efectivo por una
especialista que tuvo que pasar una
curva de aprendizaje muy grande y como
las escuelas son pocas en el mundo pocos
pacientes lamentablemente estarán con un
acceso a un equipo que pueda manejar
esto de manera adecuada
para buscar una mejor solución a este
problema en conjunto con mis mentores y
colegas
luciano rose y jorge 60 decidimos tomar
cartas en el asunto como parte de las
investigaciones de mi maestría y
doctorado juntamos herramientas
tecnológicas y la experiencia del equipo
y creamos una nueva metodología hoy con
teléfonos celulares programas de
computadora gratuitos e impresoras 3d
podemos crear estas prótesis mucho más
fácilmente
la copia del rostro de mi paciente será
obtenida a partir de múltiples fotos que
tomamos del rostro del paciente y que
luego serán cargadas a un programa de
computadora que automáticamente
conseguirá superponer todas estas fotos
y crear un modelo 3d del rostro del
paciente con esta copia conseguimos
crear una escultura digital si a mi
paciente le falta una parte del rostro y
tenemos la otra sana por ejemplo una
oreja podemos copiarla despejarla y
utilizarla o si fuera algo único como
una nariz o un labio podemos utilizar la
de su hermano de su hijo
a partir de este diseño 3d que es muy
similar a lo que un arquitecto podría
utilizar para crear esta maqueta digital
de la casa que desea construir a partir
de este diseño conseguimos materializar
la el mundo físico por medio de una
impresora una impresora 3d que capa por
capa conseguirá materializar dicho
prototipo que luego tendrá toda la forma
adaptación y hasta el más fino detalle
de la piel de nuestro paciente y que
consideramos reproducir luego
manualmente en la prótesis final un
paciente portador de una estas prótesis
se ve de esta manera sin prótesis con su
diseño digital y con la prótesis
finalizada después de todos los
procedimientos manuales
gracias a esta metodología que utiliza
herramientas tecnológicas accesibles
como un teléfono celular programas de
computadora gratuitos e impresoras 3d
redujimos o sustituimos aquella
impresión aquella copia del rostro y
paciente el proceso de la escultura está
muy avanzado y el tiempo con el paciente
se redujo a menos del 50 por ciento
eso significa que como sistema podemos
atender a más pacientes en simultáneo el
esfuerzo y la curva de aprendizaje de
los especialistas se reduce y finalmente
son menos procedimientos que hacer
cuando tengamos que repetir en una nueva
prótesis desde hace 20 años que existen
programas escáneres e impresoras 3d pero
en el flujo completo tendría que gastar
cerca de medio millón de dólares para
poder utilizarlas y gracias a que
publicamos esta metodología el hacer
prótesis faciales 3d está cada vez más
cerca a la palma de una mano
cuando hicimos esta metodología pensamos
hacerla en cambiar una realidad mundial
lo que no imaginamos es que su acogida
haya sido tan rápida hoy unas 200
fuentes en general hablan del trabajo
está traducido a 37 idiomas y lo más
importante para nosotros en realidad es
que siete países de tres continentes
diferentes están teniendo la oportunidad
de utilizarlo pero el desafío final de
automatizar toda la cadena de producción
o sea que yo a triste tal vez algún día
dos botones y me aparezca la prótesis de
acuerdo a nuestras indicaciones es parte
de nuestra mejora continua y conforme la
tecnología vaya evolucionando también lo
hará nuestra metodología pero lo que no
va a cambiar nunca es nuestra filosofía
de trabajo que es resolver problemas de
salud con tecnologías de avanzada pero
accesibles
el método tiene el mismo nombre de
nuestra ong que es más identidad porque
más allá de un rostro que devolvemos es
la identidad perdida que queremos
reconquistar en este paciente y la ong
publicó un libro con el objetivo de
poder sensibilizar a la comunidad en
general y que cuenta 20 historias de
pacientes que después de su
rehabilitación pudieron más una vez
reconquistar está este parámetro esa
vida quiero contarles la historia de
carlón y que cuando su pequeño hijo se
enteró que se dio cuenta mejor dicho que
su papá no tenía un ojito él le pregunta
papá porque tú no eres normal
como no normal hijo es que papi te falta
un ojito
dijo es que papá dios me lo pidió
prestado para alguien que lo necesitaba
y como todo niño inteligente le pregunta
entonces para algún día te van a
devolver tu ojito
y el día que carlo ni recibió su primera
prótesis se cerró un capítulo gigante en
la vida de esa familia
pero se abrió un nuevo mundo de
posibilidades en términos de perspectiva
de calidad de vida no sólo para el
paciente si de toda esa familia y otro
de nuestros queridos pacientes es hermes
quien por un cáncer perdió nariz labios
maxilar y cachetes casi llegando hasta
el ojo hacer una prótesis en él estaba
haciendo sumamente complicado recuerdo
al profesor piras ya cristian y
trabajando largas horas largas jornadas
en él y la única solución viable era
amarrar unas pitas transparentes por
detrás del rostro y técnicamente podría
ser una de las prótesis que menos gustó
al equipo pero el paciente se fue
tranquilo y satisfecho
unos días después
nos llega un correo electrónico de
hermès
se imaginan que contenía
era un carnet con una foto tres por
cuatro de hermes y que con dicho carnet
a partir de ahora podía ir gratis en
transporte público
este paciente después de su
rehabilitación
y cinco años después se atrevió a
tomarse una foto nuevamente a partir de
esta rehabilitación a hermes se le
devolvió su identidad y por consecuencia
se le permitió reintegrarse a la
sociedad la mejora en la calidad de vida
de nuestros pacientes se dan múltiples
niveles recibimos pacientes porque se
quedaron un diente porque perdieron un
diente perdieron todos los dientes o
quizás también casi todo el rostro todos
son contextos diferentes pero todos
tienen algo en común que es la necesidad
humana de recuperar capacidades no es
diagnosticar y tratar es el bienestar
general del paciente no es poner una
prótesis proponerla es devolver aquella
identidad calidad de vida y autoestima
hoy por medio de esta prótesis el
paciente no consigue volver a ver pero
lo que sí conseguimos es que la sociedad
lo vea mejor y que con su alegría
emociones e identidad de vuelta
se encuentra nuevamente bajo una
condición humana digna muchas gracias
[Música]